Narrator: It's a special
holiday edition of "Shark Tank."
And even with the grinch
in the tank...
[ laughter ]
...it's jollier than ever.
This stuff is hideous.
I hate this idea.
I can't believe
I actually agree with Kevin.
You're dead to me.
Daymond.
You're dead to me, too.
If you described hell on earth,
that would be it.
Narrator: In the tank,
hopeful entrepreneurs
get a once-in-a-Lifetime chance
to pitch the sharks
in hopes of
getting an investment
to start, grow,
or save their businesses.
Our sales were $862,000.
Whoa.
Narrator: The entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll
walk away with nothing.
He will never get share
in this market.
Ever, Ever, ever, ever!
NARRATOR:
If the sharks hear a great idea,
they're ready to invest
using their own money.
And now I'm gonna
take it all off for you.
Ooh.
Narrator: And they're willing
to fight each other
for a piece of the action.
Don't ever listen to Kevin
on that stuff. He's the worst.
So I'm actually shocked scrooge
has made you guys an offer.
I almost feel bad about it,
but not really.
[ laughs ]
NARRATOR:
Who are the sharks?
They're self-Made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Daymond John is
a fashion and branding expert
Who grew
his homemade clothing line
into the globally recognized
fashion brand fubu,
with over $6 billion
in retail sales to date.
Robert herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
Who sold his first internet
companies for over $350 million.
Lori Greiner, the queen of qvc,
holds over 100 patents and
has launched over 300 products
grossing over a half a billion
dollars in retail sales.
And Mark Cuban --
Notorious billionaire
entrepreneur, tech guru,
and the outspoken owner
of the NBA's Dallas Mavericks.
First into the tank
is an entrepreneur
from Lubbock, Texas,
with a solution to one of
the holidays' biggest headaches.
Hi. My name
is Shawn Genenbacher,
and my company is Lite-Netics.
I'm seeking $125,000 in exchange
for 20% of my business.
Now, everyone loves the festive
atmosphere of the holidays.
All the food, all the family --
Okay,
maybe not all the family.
But the decorations
and, of course, my favorite,
the lighting.
Now, there is just one problem.
Nothing can ruin
the holiday spirit quicker
than a tangled mess
of holiday light strands.
The clips, the tabs,
the glues, the screws --
All the tools needed
to keep these attached.
Well, you know, it doesn't have
to be so complicated anymore.
Introducing Lite-Netics.
[ chuckles ]
ah.
Magnetic light strands.
These are the first and only
light strands featuring a magnet
embedded at the base
of each and every socket.
This allows for the quickest
and easiest attachment
of any strands available.
So a decorating job
that once took hours to complete
can now be done in just minutes.
Let me show you.
Hmm.
Voila . Just like that.
So now you can spend less time
on the roofs
and off those ladders
and more time sipping nog
around the old yule log.
So how many of you sharks
are gonna team up with me
so we can light up this world?
Does it work
on aluminum?
It does not work
on aluminum.
How many homes have a metal
that this would stick to?
A lot of them do, actually.
It just depends on the portion
of the world you're at.
How many people know if they
have metal in the Eaves or not?
Well, I think
you can see that, can't you?
Well, I-It's real simple.
Well, metal or aluminum --
I mean...
You know, commercial side --
This is not just for resident.
But the commercial side,
a lot of these are metal.
In the residential side,
you're seeing a-a lot of --
of metal also,
just depending on your gutter.
But let's put that aside
for a second.
Okay.
Tell me about
the ones you've sold.
How have you sold those?
Well, I focused
the last couple years
on targeting
the professional installers.
They're out there working
with your commercial builders,
commercial installers
that do this on the side
during that holiday season.
For residential?
For both.
Oh, interesting.
So, which retailers
have picked you up?
I'm -- I'm working c-Currently
with some buyers
for -- for home depot.
Okay.
They --
they like the product.
They've taken this product now,
and they're taking it
to their factories
So they can get some pricing
and Costs down
for the retail market.
That's the market
that I'm trying to jump into.
Oh.
What are
the total sales?
John: Okay, how much --
Total sales, yes,
in the last year.
Last year,
we did $118,000 in sales.
We netted $38,000.
How long have you been
in business?
We've been in business the last
four seasons -- four years.
So what were your years
prior to that?
Little over $400,000
for the last 4 years.
And so you're --
You're up a little bit,
but about the same.
John:
On average, it's the same.
But it's about the same.
You're not scaling it.
What I'm having problems with
is some factories,
you know, trying to get
my costs down a little bit.
When I first started this
product and got this patent,
I pursued it, and I-I --
It's cleared?
The patent's cleared?
Yes.
Wow.
You have something here,
my friend.
Greiner: You know what
the biggest problem is,
I think is that magnets
are actually expensive.
Yes.
I've tried myself because
I've made products with magnets,
and the problem is, is you just
can't get the price down
after a certain point.
It --
because it is
what it is.
Right.
Shawn, I want --
A 50-Foot Strand
of traditional lights is --
Is how much at home depot?
Maybe $20, $25.
And how much
would yours be?
Probably $70.
Oh.
Ooh.
That's what it is currently.
Like I said, if we can work
and get that product down --
So --
Yeah, but, Shawn,
there's two problems.
Mm-hmm.
If you were talking
about a 20% difference,
if you were $25
and they were $20,
you can get
the price down.
But it --
but are we even in the business
of equaling their price?
Absolutely.
Or is that an impossible road
to go down?
I think what we're --
what you're forgetting
is -- Is if --
if you're doing it
on some of these structures,
you got to buy
the additional accessories --
the -- the clips and the tabs --
and that's just more.
But they're plastic,
so they're very cheap.
What is wrong with approaching
one of the major players...
that's a $50 difference.
...and saying,
"I own this patent,
"and I have a cost disadvantage
of my small scale.
I would like
to show you this solution"?
because it's patented.
You're not -- You don't have the
risk of them ripping you off.
Absolutely. I-I would --
Why wouldn't you do that?
That opportunity
hasn't arised yet
where I had someone come in
and --
And, you know,
offer license agreement.
But you --
but have you called them?
No, I-I have not.
Well, this is one of these deals
where -- Where I can --
I feel -- I almost feel bad
about it, but not really.
Ha!
I mean,
you want an offer?
Here's what it is.
I know how
to call the two players
that globally own
this market, okay?
I'll negotiate the deal
with them.
You have the right to override
me if you don't like the terms,
but I won't pay you the $125,000
till we sign it.
Because I'm gonna get
a massive advance on it.
But we're 50/50 partners.
Any other offers?
Let me --
Let me clear the deck, Shawn.
I think you have
a massive problem.
At a $50
price difference --
I-I don't know if there is
a residential market for this.
So I'm not sure
that's the right path.
And I got to tell you,
after four years,
you might be learning
the same thing.
I'm out.
Okay.
Anyone else?
Look, the one issue
to every professional installer
that's important to them
and is their biggest cost
is their time.
To be able to say, "Your time
is worth $50 or $100 an hour.
"I can save you
two hours per install.
This is the product
for you."
Then you don't have
to fight the behemoths,
but I would focus
on the professional installers.
I don't know how
to reach that market,
and for that reason,
I'm out.
Thank you.
Good advice,
but no check.
Greiner: You have
three problems, as I see it.
Number one
is the cost is too high,
and I don't think you'll be able
to manufacture it
ever apples to apples to
the lights that are out there.
Number two, I don't know
how many places it'll work.
Because you have to have metal
that works with the magnet,
and a lot of homes
have aluminum.
And number three is
you also have something here --
This is a large bulb.
It's more -- I think they call
it the old-Fashioned light bulb.
Yeah,
it's a c9 socket. Mm-hmm.
Yes.
And a lot of people today
are buying icicle lights
for the home
and smaller bulbs
for the home.
I don't think it's going to work
in the retail market.
I'm out.
Thank you.
Daymond?
I believe that the only
opportunity is the licenses.
I'll go head-to-head
with him,
and I'll offer you
the exact same deal,
but instead of 50%,
I'll only take 40%.
Interesting.
Why do I have to provide
all the creativity
to these deals?
Doesn't anybody have the ability
to think on their own here?
This is ridiculous.
It's a challenge here.
Greiner:
You should be flattered.
I do this for a living.
I'll give you an example.
It's the voyage-Air guitar guy
who didn't pick up the phone
and call Fender or Gibson.
He had a fantastic technology.
I picked up the phone.
Now he's in Fender guitar.
And so I'm worth
the extra 10%.
Well, he has
one of those examples.
I have four.
I do the work.
That's the difference.
I do the work as well.
You get -- You get
Mr. Wonderful.
I'm worth 10% more.
That's the way I look at it.
[ laughs ]
the Deal's gonna take me
nine months to do.
I want you to know that
it's gonna take a long time.
That's right.
It's gonna take me two.
So we need to do the deal.
It won't happen that fast.
They will want to test it.
They will want
to check their costs.
And you'll be negotiating
the whole way through.
Herjavec: But, Shawn, you got
to make a decision
because Christmas
is gonna come and go.
We need a decision.
Well, I appreciate
both of them.
Would you be willing
to go to 30%, Daymond?
Greiner: Ooh.
He didn't ask you.
No.
I'm hard on the 40%.
Shawn, I have no flexibility
in case you're thinking.
But I'll negotiate a better deal
than he'll get.
I'm gonna have to decline.
Both offers?
Yes.
Wow.
You see
a different path?
Yes. I'll continue on
with the way I've been working.
I-I got some opportunities
with some -- Some other big
wholesalers and distributors.
Good luck.
All right.
Thank you.
Shawn, you're dead to me.
[ laughs ] Best thing that
happened to you all day, Shawn.
Yeah.
John: Shawn...
you're dead to me, too.
[ laughter ]
Cuban: Second-Best thing.
Good luck.
So, Mr. Grinch
and the little happy elf
couldn't get a deal today.
We did our worst,
and that's all that counts.
He will never get share
in this market.
Ever, Ever, ever, ever!
Genebacher:
I needed a strategic partner.
I-I just think the equity,
what they wanted,
was just too much for me,
and I just wasn't prepared and
ready to -- to -- to give up.
My name is Morri Chowaiki.
I live in San Diego, California,
with my wife and three kids.
1, 2, 3. Oh!
The holiday season
in Our house is fantastic.
It's full of love, presents,
tons of good food, and laughter.
Happy Christmas!
Happy Hanukkah!
Looks great,
but maybe a little -- No.
Not on your life.
Chowaiki:
My wife celebrates Christmas.
And I celebrate Hanukkah.
Children: Yay!
My product is a solution
for the thousands and thousands
of interfaith families
that live in the United States,
and it bridges the gap
between "Ho, ho, ho"
And "Dreidel, dreidel, dreidel."
Come on, guys.
Get our orders out.
I have been selling my product
now for three years.
I've already put a second
mortgage out on our house
to make this dream come True.
We can't keep putting money
into this business ourselves.
Without an investment
from the sharks,
I fear that we just
won't make it.
Oh!
Daddy!
This product
is important to me
because it brought us together
as a family.
And to be able to provide
that same gift
to the millions of interfaith
families that are out there
would just be a wonderful
achievement in life for me.
[ chuckles ]
[ Chuckles ]
Hello, gefilte sharks.
And how are you?
[ laughs ]
My name is Morri Chowaiki,
and I'm from san Diego,
California.
My company is one life products,
and I'm here seeking $50,000
in exchange
for 15% of my company.
Sharks, chrismukkah...
[ laughter ]
...is the most wonderful time
of the year,
a time when Interfaith families
Can play spin the dreidel
while kissing
under the mistletoe.
Wouldn't it be wonderful
if interfaith families
could find a way
to truly capture the spirit
of chrismukkah?
Well, mazel toe.
Because now they can
with the Hanukkah tree topper.
It's the perfect pairing between
all these holiday traditions,
and, hey, doesn't it look great
on top of a Christmas tree?
No more debates between
Candy canes or chocolate gelt
or Santa versus Hanukkah Harry.
[ laughs ]
You get
the best of both worlds
with the Hanukkah tree topper.
[ laughter ]
together, I know we can take
the Hanukkah tree topper
to the next level and make
lots of shekels doing it.
So what do you say?
This holiday,
let's reach for the star
and sell like meshuggener!
[ laughter ]
So, I-I want to make sure
we understand this right.
Is the product simply the star
to put on top of the tree?
Yes, it is.
Can we see them,
morri?
Absolutely.
Who would like to see them?
Greiner: Here.
Cuban: We'd all like
to see them.
O'Leary: We all would.
All right. Fantastic.
Cuban: Yeah.
Oh!
Down Goes morri!
Down I go. Down I go.
There you go.
And there is --
You can turn on
the switch on that.
So -- So one lights up,
and one doesn't.
One does not.
Oh, there it is.
Exactly.
How many of these
have you sold?
I have sold approximately 12,000
of that item right there.
Of this one.
Herjavec: Where are you
selling them, morri?
Currently we are selling
in a big-Box retail store
as well as online
and in a-a flight magazine.
What do you
sell them for?
Sell those for $19.99.
They cost $2.
So we have
about a 70% wholesale Margin
and 90% retail margin.
Those are higher end.
We're at about $35.99
and about, right now, a $9 cost
because it's our first run, and
we expect costs to come down.
How much have you made
on your 12,000 units?
Our gross sales
have been $150,000.
In the last 12 months.
No.
In the last three seasons.
Whoa.
This year --
Morri, baby,
that's not a lot of sales.
Oh, well --
Bubele, come on!
You got to step up
your game.
Wait a minute.
Just wait a minute.
Morri, oy vey!
Come on!
Let me tell you something.
We've got massive potential,
and let me tell you why, okay?
[ laughter ]
first of all --
I love when the answer
to existing sales is potential.
Oh, no. This is --
This is real potential.
Or could it be, morri,
that there's a little
market confusion going on here?
Nope.
But, morri,
sales are poo-Poo.
So, here are the stats.
A national survey was done
that said that nearly 50%
of all jewish people
in the United States
have married somebody
of another faith.
So we feel
that there is a target audience
of probably somewhere
in the neighborhood
of a million to a million
and a half households
for this one item.
The retailer that we're in,
we're in about 200 --
Almost 200 stores.
Herjavec:
Which retailer is it?
Bed bath & beyond.
Is that the only retailer
you're in?
In brick and mortar, yes.
What percent of sales
are online,
and what are in retail?
I'd say 70% online,
20% in-Flight magazine,
and the rest with stores.
Morri, what are you gonna
use the money for?
Number one --
New product design.
We want to get our own website
up and running
so that we're not relying
on Sites and Commissions
and things like that.
I need some fulfillment space,
because we started
not being able to park
one car in the garage.
Now it's two cars in the garage,
and my wife --
You're doing this all
from home?
Everything. 100%.
How much money
have you put in?
About close to $130,000
of our own money.
Wow.
O'Leary: Morri, one of
the challenges about this,
it's
a seasonal business.
I hate seasonality because,
you know, you have one shot.
You either make
too much or make too little.
It's always the same problem
every year.
That's never gonna change
with --
Mr. Wonderful, I was waiting
for you bring that up.
And what's your answer?
My answer is, number one, first
and foremost, you're right.
It is seasonal.
But number two --
You're making the deal with me,
and I work
12 months out of the year.
Morri,
there's another problem.
When a family buys this,
it's once.
Mm-hmm.
They don't need to buy it again.
Subset of a subset
of a subset market,
seasonal purchase,
one-time-In-Your-Life only.
If you described hell on earth,
that would be it.
[ chuckles ]
No, I think --
I'm sorry.
I have to disagree.
In my heart, I know
we got something special
and that is -- and it's -- and
it may be a niche, but it's --
but it's small.
Well, let me tell you what
small is. Okay. So I've got --
I know what small is --
your sales.
Thank you. Well...
Hey, that's -- That's --
Numbers don't lie,
my friend.
Well, let me explain
what's coming.
I've been invited into
the largest mass-Market
big-Box store,
one of the two
largest drugstore chains,
the largest toy-Store chain,
as well as one of the largest
discount-Clothing chains.
"Invited" means to show it
or you have a purchase order?
"Invited" means to show it.
My friend, morri,
I'm out.
I understand.
You know, I can't believe
I'm going to say this,
but...
I actually agree
with Kevin.
And I don't think
you have a big enough market
for this to become
something really scalable
and a huge business
for you.
Mm-hmm.
And so for that reason,
I'm out.
Lori,
I'll be honest with you.
I want
to do business with you.
And --
Morri, she's out.
I'm out.
All right.
Let me tell you this.
You're working
in a full-Time job,
and you're working
basically out of your garage.
The biggest challenge
that I've ever experienced
with all my "Shark Tank"
Companies
has been getting
out of the garage
and getting into an office
or whatever it may be,
and growing out
of that home-Based business.
Which is what I want.
I don't expect you
to run my business.
What I want is your expertise
behind, you know,
marketing, social search-Engine
Optimization.
Look, it's what you want,
but you're not set up
to do that right now,
so for that reason, I'm out.
Okay.
I think you've done
a good job here.
But 3 years later,
you're at $60,000.
But I haven't even broke
Brick and mortar yet.
For that reason,
I'm out.
Okay.
Daymond.
You know, I-I did a deal
with, uh, a rabbi.
Sure you did.
Rabbi -- Rabbi Moshe.
Moshe. Um...
[ Laughs ]
Soundbender.
Yeah.
Are you gonna
make an offer on this?
Uh...
there's no way
this is going to be
a multi-million-dollar
business ever.
No.
Narrator:
Four sharks are out.
Daymond is morri's last chance
at getting a deal.
Are you gonna
make an offer on this?
Uh...
there's no way
this is going to be
a multi-million-dollar
business ever.
No.
I don't want scrooge
to interrupt my, uh,
thought process here.
[ laughs ]
Yeah, Christmas and Hanukkah
are about faith, and I --
I just question your judgment.
That's all.
I like --
There's product extension.
If he has that,
he may have some other stuff.
You know what? I-I think I want
to take a Gamble on you.
Uh, $50,000 for 35%
is my offer.
35%.
Wow.
Morri, why are you even
thinking about that?
I'm not looking
for control.
Okay.
I'm just looking
for a happy chrikkahmas.
35%.
Can I ask, is it e-Commerce
that you can bring?
Is it ret--
I mean, w-What --
GREINER: Morri. Morri.
You don't want to have
an "Oh, no" Moment.
This is
a licensing play.
Okay.
And this is to do bulbs
and Socks and other things,
as well
as the primary product.
You know, morri,
do me a favor.
Just -- hopefully You'll make
the right decision
and not counter
and do something crazy,
because I really want
to do the deal.
And your answer is,
morri?
My answer is...
...kiss me.
[ laughter ]
All right.
All right!
Ah.
This is for you.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Do a little dance.
All right!
Daymond, you look
like a cute elf.
[ humming ]
[ laughter ]
That's scary.
WOMAN: Hi, honey.
How are you?
We made a deal.
You made a deal?
Chowaiki:
It's a dream come True.
This is a winning
lottery ticket.
This is unbelievable.
Honey,
we're so proud of you.
Okay. Aww!
Hi, babies!
DAUGHTER:
Daddy, I miss you!
Love you!
To me,
this is showing my kids
how important it is
not to give up.
Narrator:
Last season, Marine rob Dyer
pitched his energy drink
ruckpack to the sharks.
Dyer: It's the world's first
Peak performance nutrition shot,
designed and tested
by Spec ops forces.
$150,000 from the two of us
for 20%.
I'll take $150,000
Cuban: All right.
Congratulations, guys.
Narrator: Let's see
how rob is doing now.
Dyer:
Business has really taken off
since making a deal
with Kevin and Robert.
Before we came on the show,
we had done $35,000 revenue
the entire year.
10 months later, we're coming up
on half a million dollars
in revenue.
We're even sponsoring
our very own ruckpack jet.
What do you think?
Unbelievable.
You weren't kidding.
It's the real thing.
The ruckpack jet's gonna be seen
by millions of people.
It's the number-One piece
at ever air show Across America.
So what's happening
with the walgreen order?
We're gonna roll
right into the entire chain.
So almost 9,000 stores.
Okay.
That's a big deal.
Dyer: We just signed a deal
with walgreens,
and they're gonna be putting us
in over 8,600 stores nationally.
This means a $4 million deal
for ruckpack,
and we're only gonna continue
to grow from there.
Well, let's fire
this thing up.
Whoa!
Wow!
Yeah!
DYER: Kevin and Robert
have been amazing for ruckpack.
Their help has gone way Beyond
just their checkbook.
Herjavec: Whoo!
They help us out
any time we need,
And you can tell
that they really care
about the company
and about the team.
Oh, wow.
We're gonna be
an actual contender
in the energy-Drink category,
which is unheard of
for a new guy,
all because of the help that
I've received from the Sharks.
Unbelievable.
That's awesome.
Narrator: Next into the tank
are a model and hair stylist
from Beverly hills with a way
to enhance a woman's beauty.
Hi. I'm Rachel.
And I'm Melissa.
And we are the cashmere
hair girls of Beverly Hills.
We are asking $45,000
for a 15% stake of our company.
Every woman has had
to fake it a time or two,
especially
when it comes to beauty.
Not everyone is born
with amazing hair.
But with hair extensions,
women can enhance their hair
into the hair
that they've always dreamed of.
As a professional hair Stylist
and extension expert
in Beverly hills, I know
clip-In hair extensions
are a great
nonpermanent option.
Sharks,
this is a real deal,
and there is
nothing fake about it.
And now I'm gonna
take it all off for you.
As you can see,
I'm going to unclip my hair
from my head.
Herjavec: Oh, wow.
So you can see they are
tracks attached to clips.
Wow.
Can't tell
the difference.
And I have two clips on each
side of my head like that.
And then three
that go along the back.
Here's the first one
that goes along the back.
You have a whole shetland pony
in your hair, huh?
It's all coming off.
It is all coming off.
Greiner:
A shetland pony.
As you can see, again,
it is a big difference.
So it comes
with the clips in it?
Yep.
And I'm gonna show you
how easy it is to clip back in.
Is it real human hair?
It is.
Melissa: It is 100%
all indian hair.
Cuban: Can we see it?
So there's people in India
getting their hair cut,
and they're
sending you their hair.
Melissa: We work
through a manufacturer,
and they're actually doing
all the Supplying.
Weird.
They actually go out and collect
the hair, put it together.
There -- There's
actually hair auctioners.
Come on.
And they collect different
qualities of hair and suppliers.
But --
There's
really low-Grade hair,
and you could go up
to very high quality.
So that -- my next question is,
how much is it per extension?
The cost for us on average
is $105.
We retail these
for $399.
How many pieces
do you get for $399?
You get a full set of cashmere
hair that is seven tracks.
How do you know with certainty
it's human hair?
How -- I mean --
[ laughs ]
Well, no,
but I'm -- I'm serious.
No, no, no. Really.
This is -- This is True.
You know, listen, it might be
from the underbelly of a yak.
We have tested out
about 20 suppliers,
so we'll get their hair
over to us as samples.
For each batch?
Yes.
All cuticle intact,
it's called Remy.
We deal with the manufacturer
and supplier
that only deals
with Remy hair.
In this calendar year, how much
of this are you going to sell?
We have been in business
for six months,
and we have sold
a total of $38,000.
But other people can buy
from that same supplier.
Yes.
Correct?
That's a possibility.
Anybody can.
Right.
I have 10 years
as a professional hair stylist
as an extension expert.
So I know what girls are looking
for and what they want.
I've been a model
for the last 10 years,
and I've been
wearing hair extensions myself
for a really long time.
I used to have
to make my own.
I would actually take apart
other ones from other companies
and sew them together
so that they were full enough
and thick enough and --
There's nothing worse.
Nothing.
There isn't.
It takes a long time,
and also I didn't want
to have to wear
a ton of metal clips on my head.
Let me ask you a question.
Does it concern you --
Let's talk "Guy meets girl."
Mm-hmm.
Guy looks at girl...
[ Laughs ]
I don't even want to know
where this is gonna go.
...says,
"I really like this girl.
She has spectacular hair.
Fantastic."
The next morning...
a couple of dates go by,
the special evening arrives,
and then you find out
it's just all false advertising.
Well, isn't that with a lot
of things women do, you know?
I mean, do we have
a problem with this?
A little bit --
We cheat a little bit.
Why not enhance something
when someone could go
from an 8 to a 10?
Taking a pretty girl
and even making her prettier.
[ laughs ]
HERJAVEC: So you've sold me
it's a great product, okay?
$38,000 in sales in 6 months --
Great start.
Yep.
How do you now get all the women
to know all about it?
Number one is we really want
to make instructional videos
that are going
to basically
help sell the product
for us because --
Sell it where, though?
Online, uh...
online. Oh, let me --
Okay, but, Rachel,
how are people gonna know
you're out there to come to
your website to watch the video?
Because we make our own beauty
blogs, we utilize instagram.
We -- Social media has take--
A huge help for us.
We know what works,
and we're --
right,
b-But the challenge --
And where Robert was trying
to get to --
The challenge isn't will
you have a successful
business, right?
Absolutely.
You guys are there,
right?
You've just got to
keep on doing --
What are you
talking about, mark?
They've got $38,000
in sales.
No, no, no.
They know what they're doing.
Exactly. 'cause every business
has to start somewhere.
And we're actually -- We're
planning on going into salons,
and we want to have
cashmere hair parties.
We want to be able
to bring the hair to you.
You haven't had one yet,
have you?
No, but we are having one
at the end of the month.
The challenge is,
can you grow that enough
to become a company that creates
a return for an investor?
Your --
You asked for $45,000.
Correct.
And the reality is,
if you guys
hustle and grind enough...
mm-hmm.
...you can generate that
$45,000, given your margins,
with just $90,000
in sales or less.
And so while I think
this is a great business,
I don't think
this is a great business
suited for an investor,
and so for that reason, I'm out.
Oh. Okay.
I think we could grow
a lot faster, though,
if we actually
do have an investment.
So,
here's a question.
When you look
at yours --
'cause there's tons
of extensions out there.
Where do your prices compare
to what's already out there?
Our price is more expensive
than almost all of the
other clip-In hair
extension companies.
But there's
a good reason for it.
A lot of clip-In hair extensions
sell for half of our price.
And it's because
the quality is not good.
You cannot buy that kind of hair
for that cheap.
You have -- You've gone
to the high end, or at
least you claim that.
You're telling me it's not
yak hair. I'm gonna believe you.
But for an investor like me
to look at this and say,
"How am I gonna turn this
into a multi-Million-Dollar
business?"
I don't think I am.
I don't see the strategy
that gets me there.
And for that reason...
I'm out.
Okay.
Melissa, are you okay?
Yeah.
All right,
'cause you seem like you're --
You're frustrated,
you're melting a little bit.
I-I guess I stand
behind this so strongly.
All right.
The challenge with this is this
is purely about marketing.
And marketing
is the black hole of a business.
And, uh...
well, I think even in the past
six months, we've been --
We've done pretty Well ourselves
getting it out there.
No, you have. You have.
And this doesn't mean
that you guys --
So if we had help
from Somebody like you,
it only would make se--
You don't want help
from me on hair.
[ both laugh ]
trust me on that one.
It's a good point.
I would have to agree
with mark.
I don't think
that this is something
that you need an investor
at -- at this time.
And I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
There's one thing you said here
today that I think is unique.
I think
doing these home parties --
I think that if you focused
on that --
I'm with Lori.
I like the idea of the hair
parties at salons and so on.
But you haven't done it.
Today,
for me to invest in it,
I-I wish there was more
substance to the strategy.
That's all.
Well, I --
and I'm gonna --
Look, I wish you the best
of luck. I'm out.
Rachel: Lori?
[ chuckles ]
we know that you can
help us a lot.
I think that there are
two products, right?
Those that are revolutionary,
and those that are like
other things out there.
And when it's like other things
already out there,
you have to really try
much Harder
to get yourself known
and to beat the competition.
I think it's going to be
really hard for you
to get ahead
of that competition.
So I'm out.
Thank you.
Okay, thank you.
Good luck, you guys.
Cuban: Good luck, guys.
You'll be fine.
It's a very nice product.
Good luck.
Good luck, guys.
Melissa: Thank you.
Great hair. Great product.
Both: Thank you.
Good luck.
Greiner: Thank you, guys.
Herjavec: Well, she certainly
believed in it.
Passionate --
Very passionate.
Greiner:
Very passionate, but --
they have nothing.
And I'll tell you what else.
Where can I find a woman
with Real hair?
[ laughter ]
RACHEL: I think we came here
wanting a deal
and wanting everything
that went along with it.
It's okay. Take a deep breath.
Take a deep breath.
Melissa: It is crushing
and a disappointment.
But life goes on.
Narrator:
Next into the tank is a duo
with a new take
on a favorite Christmas Staple.
Hi, sharks.
I'm Evan Mendelsohn.
And I'm Nick Morton.
Our company is Tipsy Elves,
and our slogan is
"Not your mama's
Christmas sweater."
We are seeking
a $100,000 investment
for 5% of our company.
Before Tipsy Elves,
Christmas sweaters were old,
they smelled terrible,
and you could only find them
at your local Thrift store.
Tipsy Elves re-creates
those Christmas sweaters
of the past
with fun, witty, high-Quality
Christmas sweaters
that the whole family
can enjoy.
And they fit great,
too.
But don't take it from us,
sharks.
See for yourselves.
Both: welcome to
the Tipsy Elves fashion show.
John: [ laughs ]
O'Leary: [ sighs ]
first we have Greg.
Greg is wearing
our runaway sleigh sweater,
where Santa's sleigh
gets the best of him.
He's also wearing our popular
Christmas bomber Hat.
Next up, we have adry.
She's wearing
our elf sweater.
She's also wearing
our believe Fanny Pack.
Next, we have Brad.
Brad is wearing our popular
Hanukkah Sweater.
Next up, we have Nikki.
Nikki is wearing our
bucktooth Rudolph sweater dress.
Oh, that's cute.
Greiner: Yeah.
Morton: She's also wearing
our reindeer animal hat.
Mendelsohn: Last but certainly
not least, we have Andrew.
Andrew is wearing our
reindeer matchmaker jump suit,
which is brand-New
this season.
Zip it up
and watch them kiss.
All right, sharks,
so you've seen
a little bit
of what we have to offer.
Our beautiful models here
are gonna be
handing out a sweater
to each one of you
that we've picked out
along
with Our bomber hat.
Herjavec: Thank you.
Thank you.
Morton: The idea behind it
was that there were
a bunch of Tipsy Elves
up in Santa's --
You know,
making these sweaters.
You guys look great.
Now it's time
to get down to business.
This stuff is hideous.
Why don't you give us
some sales numbers?
Mendelsohn:
We started in 2011.
2012,
our sales were $862,000.
Which gave us $1.35 million
in Sales in those 2 years.
Wow.
A little more than half
of our orders came from amazon.
This year, we started
dabbling in wholesale.
For example, one major retailer,
urban outfitters,
placed an order with us.
I own the ugliest sweater
company in history, coogi,
the ones that bill Cosby
used to wear.
Yeah.
And they're ugly.
Ugly!
No, trust me.
They're really ugly.
Um, and the challenge we have
is the returns.
So how much does
each one cost to make?
$12 --
$11.40 per sweater.
And what do you
sell them for?
Sell them for $65.
Oh!
Wow.
Greiner:
What made you say one day,
"I'm gonna make
ugly Christmas sweaters"?
MORTON:
Evan was a lawyer,
and it wasn't a job
that he wanted to pursue.
I had a background
in s.E.O.,
So I started doing
internet businesses,
like mostly
informational websites
where I'd make money
off ad revenue.
I saw there was a high demand
for Christmas sweaters
based on search volume.
Why get into the wholesale
retail side of it?
Doesn't that
just complicate things
and increase
your overhead?
Once you take
a wholesale account,
you've got
to support them,
you've got to interact
with them,
you've got to make
their buyers happy,
you've got to talk
about next season.
At our core,
we're an e-Commerce site.
Why risk it and go into a
new area where you're uncertain
and you've got guys
like Daymond
who know this stuff inside
and out competing with you?
John: To mark's point,
when you come over to our side,
you're gonna have to be able
to take back inventory,
you're gonna have to have
a warehouse the size of,
you know, two blocks.
It's gonna be a lot.
Sure.
O'Leary: Everybody's
echoing the same thing.
You shouldn't take this
to retail, in my opinion.
We're pursuing
the online strategy
as -- As much as we can.
Retail is the drug
that everybody goes for.
They look at that order,
and they say, "Wow,
I got to fill that."
We have retailers
coming to us,
and it's just hard for us
to turn it -- to turn it down.
Look, it sounds like
what you guys are good at
is s.E.O.
And selling online.
But I'm getting the sense
that you think that there's
a ceiling there.
Yeah. We're -- We're pretty
maxed out on s.E.O.
2011, we were number one
on "Ugly Christmas sweater,"
"Ugly Christmas Sweaters."
HERJAVEC: Do you guys do
this full time?
I quit last year
to focus on this full time.
And I was getting paid about
$170,000 a year plus bonus,
so it was a bit
of a wake up --
Wow.
You wake up one night.
You got a $170,000 job, you say,
"Ugly Christmas Sweaters!"
I mean,
I'm -- I'm a risk-Adverse guy.
It's a testament to --
to me believing in this.
Like, I-I really
wouldn't walk away
from a $170,000 job
on a -- on a whim.
Okay, but we know
the sweaters are ugly,
but also the valuation
is ugly.
Why don't you try and defend
why this is worth $2 million?
The reason our valuation
is at that point
is last year, we -- You know,
we had $862,000 in sales.
It would have --
if we would have not run out,
we would have had
a little over a million.
Well, I'm looking at it, saying
you have to give a discount
for the fact there's risk in
the seasonality in the return.
Yeah, you know what? Don't ever
listen to Kevin on that stuff.
He's the worst
at valuations.
I'm very good
at it, actually.
I mean, you guys have --
your -- your problem
is not valuation,
all right.
If you're going to grow --
Really?
Yeah, because some of us know
how to grow past the valuation.
Some people look backwards.
Some of us look forward.
So, Mark, why don't you give
them a $4 million valuation?
But doesn't matter.
The valuation isn't the issue.
Well, that's --
It doesn't matter.
It's where you can go.
But the problem I have is that
you really haven't explained
how you're going to grow.
I know you guys hate
when it sounds like people
are, you know, getting away
from their core competency.
It -- it probably sounds
like that.
But it's -- It's really
easily duplicating
what's worked here,
and from our point of view,
we're maxing out everything
we can possibly think of
when it comes
to the E-Commerce side.
And that's the problem.
Trying to do everything
is what scares me significantly.
And so even though I think
you've got a good business,
a growing business,
I'm out.
Greiner: I think you're
on a really good start,
but there's other companies
that do this.
There's nothing unique.
I'm out.
I'm gonna make you an offer.
Here's how it works.
I'm gonna give you
the $100,000.
I want $2 a sweater
till I recapture my 100K,
then it drops to $1 a sweater
in perpetuity.
What equity
are you taking?
Zero. Zero equity.
And would you be involved
in the business,
or would you
mostly just be treating it
kind of like
as a source of capital?
I-I work with All
my entrepreneurs,
and I do everything I can
to optimize
'cause our incentives
are aligned.
I'm about money.
John:
So I'm actually shocked.
Scrooge has made you guys
an offer.
Do you like his offer?
I'd love to hear if --
if there's any other
offers on the table,
but we're definitely
interested.
Herjavec: So, it's an
interesting offer from Kevin.
It's actually not
that bad an offer.
It's bad,
but not that bad.
I love the fact
that you left
a $175,000-a-year job
to do this,
because that tells me
you're all in, my friend,
and I love that level
of commitment to it.
There's no going back
for you.
No.
I don't have a problem
with the retail.
You know, I think
when you start out,
you try everything.
So here's my offer
to you.
$100,000 for 10%.
Daymond's being very quiet.
So we'd also like to --
Yeah.
Yes, he is.
What are you doing?
Robert -- $100,000,
10% of the company.
Kevin -- $2 Per sweater
until you get your money back,
I'm not greedy.
I don't need a --
till you get $100,000 back,
and then $1 in Perpetuity.
Yes, that's correct,
Daymond.
And you're
going to do what?
You're the clothing man.
Yeah, um...
Oh, this is hard.
Narrator:
Two sharks are out.
Nick and Evan have two offers
on the table
from Robert and Kevin,
but the clothing expert,
Daymond, is on the fence.
Oh, this is hard.
I'm really --
I'm falling in love
with the product
and the guys.
I just -- I still have inventory
of ugly sweaters.
Exactly.
That's the challenge.
And you'll be selling those
to me.
[ laughs ]
My challenge is exactly
what mark has been saying.
This is very seasonal.
You guys are doing great.
You guys are doing
what I cannot do online, s.E.O.
You're gonna go
to these big guys,
and after they're
through with you guys,
they just let it go.
Mendelsohn: And it's not --
We're not relying on
their business. It's --
It's just adding --
right, but if you're not relying
on their business,
then I can't be of service
to you.
You guys can go to $5 million
and $10 million without anybody.
And --
but you can help add
to what we're doing
on the online side with your
distribution channels and...
I can't.
I can't add to that.
You guys
are already doing that.
That's what
mark is saying.
He's a retail king.
So if you're going
the retail strategy --
I'm the retail king.
I can make --
I can make goods for you,
but you're making the goods
at the same price, so...
...I'm out.
O'Leary: So you have two offers
on the table.
You basically have one from me
that doesn't take any
of your equity away.
I give you $100,000.
You pay me $2 a sweater
until I get my capital back
and then $1 in perpetuity.
Or you have
an offer from Robert,
which was $100,000
for 10% equity.
Evan, I'm just really
investing in you guys.
I think that you can
build this up.
I think the college market
is gonna go huge for you guys.
I want to participate
in the company.
Kevin just wants to suck money
right off the top.
You know,
in the spirit of Christmas,
I'm not stealing
your equity like Robert is.
There's a lump of coal
over there.
[ indistinct whispering ]
Mr. Wonderful...
...we appreciate your offer,
but, Robert,
we accept your offer.
Excellent, guys.
Thank you.
O'Leary: Oh!
Excellent. Yeah.
Greiner: Congratulations.
Thank you very much.
Good job, guys.
Good job.
Thank you.
Very, very impressive.
Congratulations, guys.
John:
Congratulations.
Wow. Great job.
Great job, guys.
Morton: Whoo!
MENDELSOHN: That was good.
That's good.
Yeah,
that was awesome.
Kevin, how many versions
of a royalty deal
can you possibly do?
That's why I love me.
[ chuckles ]
whoo!
MENDELSOHN: Yes!
Tipsy Elves!
A deal with Robert was really
a-a Christmas wish for us.
Yeah, our Christmas dreams
definitely came True today.
All: Tipsy Elves! Whoo!